so if you're like our family you've
still got leftover candy from Halloween
and Valentine's so this Easter some
non-candy Easter basket ideas for all
ages with prices that range from three
bucks to no more than twenty dollars
let's find some gifts our kids are going
to love but are not going to break the
bank parenting and lifestyle expert
Amanda mushrow loves the idea of giving
preschooler toddler an early elementary
school kids dough for fun tactile
sensory play land of dough is
eco-friendly even the glitter is
compostable my son always loves this
because they give these little shovels
and as you dig it's still bright and
colorful and again I just think the
Bunny and the peep are so adorable for
the kiddos obsessed with Dragons or
surprise inside activities these dig it
dragon's eggs come with a tool and
inside you'll find your surprise and
it's only 2.95 so I love the idea of
it's inexpensive and super cute tile
building blocks you can get super
creative with this latest device from
magformers made into a fidget my teen
and my tween were like what you know
they keep snagging this one off of my
table so this is also a good one Easter
brunch so they get it in their Easter
basket and then they have something to
keep them entertained during brunch and
soft and plush Huggers from Wild
Republic The Fill inside all from
recycled plastic they come in 40
different characters so you can really
find any of your kids favorite animals
and it can give them a little hug so
again you can put on their basket on the
stroller on their bike
and you can find most of these items on
Amazon did